hey guys Pete peppers here and we are
looking at this new game blossom blast
saga which has actually been around for
a while now and it looks like it's
finally getting ready to be released on
mobile I don't know if there'll be a
Facebook version I haven't seen that at
all but I did see that they put out they
they started the Facebook page for it
and got the the Google Playstore now it
shows a pre-register which I guess means
that it should be coming out really
shortly so I've been playing this since
you know quite some time a few months it
feels like they this is one of the first
games that they did where the new trend
seems to be that they put it out in an
early early beta and then they test it
live and so this has been around for a
while
but it seems like they've done a lot to
make it really cool and we'll just look
at some of the gameplay and talk about
what you can expect from blossom blast
so here is here is our character her
name is blossom and it's showing us that
it's you know we're gonna link color the
same color flowers right so it's a line
linker game we have the flowers grow as
you go you can go in any direction as
long as they're touching each other and
flowers can make other buds bloom if
they're big enough so whenever we make a
match where the oops whenever we make a
match that's big enough to make the
flower explode
you'll see that it also blow up the ones
next to it so we're gonna we just have
to get points on this level so we'll try
to make the biggest link that we can and
you also see how
here at the top we have a meter whenever
the meter is completely full you'll see
the flowers shake a little bit and
that's gonna make even a bigger
explosions so as you can see the the
meters filling up and watch how we get
watch the explosion we get here see how
it effects a larger area you get a nice
chain reaction then that will complete
the level so that's pretty neat and I'll
go ahead and look at some of the
different level types here so the map is
really cool again and on the map you'll
see we have different different types of
levels the first one we just played was
the gold cup that's where you have to
score points we have ones that have
weeds on them you have to remove the
weeds
these ones are explode the big bud
there's a number on it and I'll show you
that in a second
so we'll just go back down here and get
one of these earlier bloom the big big
bud levels I guess we should probably go
on the very first one because it will
give us a description so here we go
level 4 isn't obviously not a very hard
level but we'll look at the instructions
that go along with it there's our big
bud right there link bud to the same
color into them so this chain will go
all the way up and it'll hit this and
you'll see that however many we had will
count towards it now you can also make
an explosion right next to it and
that'll also work towards the count
so one of the things that takes a little
bit look me a little bit of time I
should say is which direction to start
your chains from you have to think that
this is whenever you're the last one
that you link to is going to be the one
that's going to grow so in this case if
I want to move these red ones down so
that I can connect right through there
then I'd want to start at this end if I
go this way I could explode this one
right in front of it or explode this one
but if I explode this one over here it
won't actually do much to the actual
buds so you your two choices really are
to go this way which will clear these
out and bring the red down or what I
think is probably better is to explode
this one and then the Reds will come
down anyways see that so it's um
terribly tricky but it takes some
getting used to
especially if you're used to playing
swiping games because obviously you
don't swipe one out of the way you just
are looking for chances to make a nice
line that'll go where you want it to and
this will actually blow it up because
now we have way more than three that
we're gonna connect here and that's how
bloom the big buds works so there's lots
of other stuff too I mean there's going
to be blockers in your way there's gonna
be different board layouts where it's
not so easy to get to them but if you're
thinking about how you're where you're
starting your line or your link when
you're finishing it and how it's gonna
affect things as far as where what's
going to be left and what what you're
gonna see whenever it's gone then you
can start to make a plan to get done in
this few moves as possible
so the last one that we saw is the weeds
and again I'm going to scroll back down
there a little bit because we'll see
what the instructions actually are but
it's a the weeds is just it like a sort
of like a blocker you want to get close
so that you can destroy them by hitting
them and we'll look at the instructions
on this and then we'll long talk about
some of the other strategy stuff so the
weeds came back link buds next to them
until they go away so anything that you
do that's gonna make an explosion that's
gonna damage the weeds so you know it's
a it's an easy game to pick up when if
one of the earlier versions I'm not sure
which one but it was it was really
difficult I guess they were tweaking
things to make it you know challenging
it was it was actually I would say one
of the harder' games at one point but
they've they've since definitely
adjusted it so it's not so bad anymore
so it's a you know quick learning curve
there's there's class you'll see like
glass some of the times they'll be
they'll be like hidden under class where
you have to make a match from the
outside to go underneath the glass but
that's pretty straightforward I don't
think I need to make anything special
about that there'll be different kinds
of blockers you're gonna see you get you
get to the point where there's some
crows on the board and some other stuff
so it's really I think it's it's
developed into one of the one of the you
know a really nice polished game at this
point you can see the graphics are
really nice
it's got 120 levels
so there's plenty to do check it out and
what I find interesting is since it like
I said it did start from the beginning
from a very early thing it's cool to see
how they changed things to make it more
exciting and more fun for players and I
think it really is it will be popular
it'll be one of the more popular ones
out of the out of the brand new type of
games that they seem to continually try
to add rather than just sticking to the
match-three format so what do you think
let us know leave a comment below and
tell us what you think if you think
it'll be a popular one if you like the
graphics if you think it'll be the kind
of game that you want to see more they
just recently released the very early
version of sky bright saga which is
another line linker which I think the
mechanics are pretty interesting in that
one but it's in the real early stages so
you know it'll definitely get to where
it plays a lot better and looks a lot
better but make sure you subscribe to my
channel so that you can get videos like
this to find out what's going on in the
gaming world and like the video if you
found it helpful share it with your
friends so they can see what to expect
and I'll see you soon thanks